hey welcome to the monitor as always I
am Peter Reuben senior editor at wire
bringing you the best in pop culture for
the week this week we've got a full
quiver of new releases because I am for
some reason an archer now we have a
comic book that i'm looking forward to
because it is co-written by one of my
favorite comedians we have a video game
that is not the video game you might
assume i'm going to talk about for the
week but first we have a new james bond
movie skyfall this is i believe the 170
third bond movie it is also 50 years
since the first actual real canonical
bond movie dr. no and this brings maybe
the most critical firepower to it of any
bond movie it is directed by sam mendes
who directed american beauty and
revolutionary road it has Dame Judi
Dench of course as M it also has Javier
Bardem as one of these shady and
characters in the film this one is a bit
more mortality obsessed than other bond
movies it follows bond coming back from
the dead in a sense and getting on to an
interesting storyline that involves em
Judi Dench's character in the head of
mi6 we also have a new Q quartermaster
that the tech guru who gives bond all
his lovely playthings played this time
by ben wishaw who you might recognize
from Cloud Atlas if you were one of the
10 people who saw Cloud Atlas and coded
to teal palm print only you can fire it
Mehsud a random killing machine more of
a personal statement
q 7i 0 7 but that is out this weekend it
is going to make probably i'm just going
to be conservative and safe three and a
half billion dollars at the box office
domestically so you could be one of
those people because you like being in
know right so go check that out this
week but now talk about video games
thank you okay so halo 4 is out this
week let's talk about a different title
that happens in space and that is what
Angry Birds Star Wars what's that you're
saying that's two different games that's
two different things no does not it is
one thing and it is out this week for
your phone of the I variety Rovio is
bringing us with a little help from the
now disney-owned Lucasfilm conglomerate
every bird Star Wars it brings elements
of the original angry birds game and
elements of the really well received and
a lot of fun to play angry birds space
from last year but you now have birds
that wield lightsabers and repel lasers
you have birds that are giant and wiki
appearing shaped they look like cookies
there Chewbacca birds that bust through
everything you have r2d2 birds I'll
trying to make a bird pun in and did not
come together you r2d2 birds that will
fly through force fields and the like
there are there are spaced elements
there are terrestrial elements and let's
be honest you can't play halo 4 when
you're on the bus but you can't play
Angry Birds Star Wars so pick bad up
back to you okay thank you for that okay
I can't believe you're playing another
one of those but I'm not going to judge
this is all you this is that's your
segment man so you you run with that but
let's let's talk about comics for a
little bit now as I mentioned in
previous week's Marvel has begun their
Marvel now initiative which is
essentially a universe wide reboot with
giving their major superheroes and super
hero teams kind of issue number one
starting over new run for everyone and
this week we've got not one of their
marquee superheroes but we have Deadpool
the wisecracking Wade Wilson the Merc
with the mouth what's interesting about
deadpool number one this week or this
the Marvel now run of Deadpool it is
being written by Brian Posehn and Jerry
Dugan Brian Posehn you I would certainly
recognize from his recurring roles on
everything from just shoot me to the
Sarah Silverman show he was he and Steve
Agee played the gay couple next door to
Sarah Brian Posehn was also in the great
comedians of comedy kind of documentary
about Patton Oswalt tour of crazy all
comedians anyway Brian Posehn very very
funny man very very devout metalhead not
that that has anything to do with
Deadpool but he and Jerry are devoting
their their penmanship and power to this
to Deadpool with art by Tony Moore and
this is not your average serious
canonical Marvel title this is done with
their tongue planted as firmly in their
cheek as it can be without it just
straight bursting through their cheek
and out into the naked air but
definitely worth a pick up if you like
kind of the off-kilter stuff if you are
a Deadpool fan or if you just like a
little humor in your comics so that is
it for this week on the monitor as
always let us know if you have any
comment suggestions love or hate email
us at the monitor at wire calm we will
be back next week but until then
inspirational catchphrase here
you